foreign
it's working and I want to thank you
guys for making a work merch came up
with this wild idea
let's get a mustache for Mark Dice he
needs a mustache bro it'll be a good
look well cop stash would be a good look
on him not only has Mark died Mark Dice
replied on our video asking him to get a
mustache but people have been asking him
now generically in his comments like hey
man get him he's like I'll think about
getting a mustache but he won't call on
the [__] he won't think about coming
on our show but he'll think about the
mustache [__] you Mark I'm gonna I'm on
a I'm on a [__] tear today [__] Mark
Dice too because he won't get a Mustang
because he won't come on the show
because he'll consider changing his
entire aesthetic but when we said hey
we'd love to have you on the show I
don't really go on shows yeah you do you
do go on shows it's how people know the
[__] you are is that a Mark Dice
impression no it's pretty yelling at him
this time it's pretty good it's pretty
good it's my Kevin Brennan Impressions
nobody does who you are you got to do
shows Mark people say we're the mustache
or shows really if you think about it I
want try it on people try it on bud go I
want everyone to go find me every
incident where Mark Dice was on a show
okay so I could tell him this for [__]
you you don't go on shows if this was
[__] Tim pool or that fat [__] the
quartering asking you to come on you'd
go on their show I don't [__]
[__] me I don't know if that's true
I don't think so I don't think he likes
those guys
he'd go on and tell him he doesn't like
them that's fair he wouldn't go on hey
Mark come on and tell us you don't like
yeah I don't even care if you don't like
us just come on tell me to my face
well punch you right in that mustache
did you already assume he's gonna have
that mustache better
because if you're not gonna come on the
show and you're not gonna have the
[__] mustache then you're dead to me
oh you have to do one Mark sorry not
true then the other ones
tell the kid
okay anyway Mark has been on a [__]
Terror lady and it's been really fun
Terror of not coming on our [__] show
okay well all right look Marsh let's try
to hold off on that I know that you were
very hurt
but we need to do is we need to we we
need we need to muster through this
through the pain okay of him not coming
on or having a mustache yet to be honest
with you he's not you're really letting
everybody down on on multiple fronts you
know I like Mark Dice it bit aside for
one quick second this will be like the
second time that we've made a video
where we're you know we're talking about
it we think he's cool but we bust his
balls and he always comments on the
videos because he kind of gets it unlike
other people that flip out because he
does it to the people too but he's
always been like yeah I guess you're
right I'll grow a mustache that's fine
I'm like all right so let's see
time during his interview he's [__]
without the mustache his upper lip area
looks like the Atari logo he Mark you
need the stash Bud it looks just like
the Atari logo well after successfully
dodging the question when it was brought
up the first time during his interview
with Tim Poole this week in the final
few minutes of the two hour stream
Stephen Crowder admitted I've been
saying all along and no I'm not applying
for a job at the daily wire anybody who
thinks that obviously isn't familiar
with my work I'll get into them later
but thanks to Tim Poole's co-host Luke
radowski not letting Stephen Crowder
weasel out with another non-answer and
thanks to my tour hey Luke can I ask you
a question maybe I don't know this much
about Luke
obedient Adam Crigler I don't know he's
a [__] Twitter cartoon character is
what he is obedient Adam Crigler Hey
listen
who does what he says but he's told
um real quick
is Luke from Florida
don't know
take it off
honestly can I can I take it one step
further sure if he's from Florida
take it off
no
they're saying yes he's from Florida I
don't care take it off anyway
he lives in Florida half the year I want
to Corner this [__] guy like in high
school and go take it off
give me take it that's not yours you
didn't earn he just gives it to you
that's right he's from New York and he
might live in Florida part of that's not
from you're not Floridian
no and how long has he been in Florida I
know I'm from New York but I'm Florida
man now I I check all the boxes he
doesn't do any hurricanes yeah you've
never done any hurricanes remember that
Harvey K party
what clubs are you doing you never get
caught in the but you never did Coke in
the back of corner deck you have an
AK-47 and a gut hanging out of your
flowered shirt
you don't have a bunch of plastic
flatting at cups in your cupboard he
doesn't even have any cats Chad
and with that we start supporters only
mode
there is your free bypours there is your
free preview
Royce was like it's getting way too
funny in here I don't want poor people
to be happy
poor people should never be happy and
motivates them to work harder get them
the [__] out of here and hit his head on
the door on the way out beat it poor
people
paywall going up
[Laughter]
beef true poor ass losers
[__] [__] oh man see that's how we
get people to sign up we shame them you
poor
and thanks to my 250 in super chats I
spent 250 in super cats during the show
trying to get Tim Poole to ask I started
off pretty strong at 100 but then I
dialed it back to 50 a pop no no realize
you could write just somebody thanks it
was it was one 100 Super Chat and then
150 dollars no it was at 75 two dollar
ones the minimum
foreign
like they do to you sometimes yeah write
10 sentences come on question we have
now heard it from I gotta get on buy me
a coffee and figure out if there's a
[__] limit for that too because my
God yeah I know people just some people
write like people buy one coffee and
then they're like oh I'm gonna just
write the entire [__] Old Testament
they get two sentences out of me Mouse
I'll play the clip in just a moment and
you can see it for yourself that his
story about walking away from 50 million
dollars is BS his whole story is BS what
would it take for you to walk away
150 million dollars because it's true uh
not getting 120 million like you wanted
yeah that's literally what it is yeah
that's exactly what I did I actually
have a bunch of Clips because I would
easily walk away from 150 000 a year job
if I wanted 300 000 a year good thought
I deserved it yeah
because that's like two years I mean
it's a lies that Stephen Crowder has
injected into the conservative media
ecosystem strictly for his own Financial
benefit after being left without a major
Network paying him have spread far and
wide and you know this terrifies me
whenever Mark Dice has a [__] 27
minute long video because he talks so
fast as it is it's like how much
information did you squeeze into a 27
minute video
uh it's it's with with Mark with like
Mark Dice it's Mark Dice has like a
three-hour podcast of somebody who talks
slow
like here's a perfect example Mark dies
26 minute a 27 minute uh video is
equivalent in words to a three-hour Lex
Friedman show yeah there you go yeah
maybe three and a half hours because
he's very slow yeah I know
I saw he blocked you
well probably because you could try do
you like some blue [__] him thing
yeah yeah probably doesn't like that
yeah oh anything about how the business
side of being a professional YouTuber
Works think that he's leading some
selfless cause when the cause is to get
him his 30 million dollars a year his
counter offer which was rejected by the
daily wire after their initial 12 and a
half million dollar somebody said 20
minutes of work dice it's 72 hours of
Teddy's spaghetti
here offer some people are asking if it
was that you guys could say every word
Vox day has ever said in a 27 minute
video Yeah in this terrible blog where
that terrible bloggy had counter offered
that's what people are asking so they
went
from my understanding what the agent is
they said okay here's a number and this
is 100 of everything and uh my agent who
was unbelievable he's just again he's
left the big agencies he's gay he's
fighting the good fight oh my agent's so
good he other agencies won't even take
okay wait wait he's what I'm sorry let's
let's see he's so good he's not even in
Hollywood my agent is so good he sleeps
with me
that's how good this guy is
well he's just again he's left the big
agencies he's gay he's the number one
entertainment agent in South Carolina
and again I want to be clear what he
runs the number one talent agency in the
Carolinas both North and South it's huge
excluding Charlotte if you exclude to
Charlotte because that's a different
Market that's a different complicated
but outside of the Charlotte
in Port Richey area yeah and Myrtle
Beach Charlotte Charlotte still belongs
to Ric Flair's guy he's had an
arrangement since the Crockett days he's
the best he's the best one that has
three DUIs
in the town I have one of the best
entertainment agents in the world he
represents Enzo oh really
and you can't sign that
oh [__] here's a number and this is 100
of everything and uh my agent who is
unbelievable he's just again he's left
the big agencies he's gay he's Latino
and he's to the right of Attila the Hun
no Crowder he's not to the right of
Attila hun that's [__] because he's
gay those two things cannot coexist in
the same ecosystem no
and he's an agent
Cuban he also doesn't like Porter
let's hear this guy out wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute does he have
a Cuban lawyer who hates Puerto Ricans a
gay human lawyer he's stealing your bit
watch he's about to steal your bits
agencies he's gay he's Latino needs to
the right of Attila the Hun he's Cuban
he also doesn't like Puerto Ricans but
that's all they have to ask about
because
are you [__] kidding me right he's a
he's a gay Cuban who hates Puerto Rico
no I'm not I am not not your guy yes
he's the guy
that's his [__] that's a shame
that's a shame really it's a shame
first off Cuba if he was really Cuban
Cubans don't like to be called Latino we
called it we're Hispanic that's true
Latinos go home
it's hilar because he can get away with
it
um
we get away with stuff all the time you
know if you're not a [__] you get away
with anything if you're not bound by
YouTube's terms of service you know what
the most shameful thing you ever did
Stephen was stay demonetized on YouTube
and then continue to be a
H you know you didn't even like you
didn't get cool you didn't get cool yeah
at least we got edge here and said well
then [__] it we'll make gay people and
Jews every day then they're gonna pay me
you still played the game for no pay
you're the biggest fan on YouTube we're
gonna make fun of gay people and Jews
every day and someday that's just Dave
Rubin
you managed to be the biggest but the
difference is Dave Rubin loves Puerto
Ricans
they're thinking of adopting one uh-huh
where he said well if you want 100 of
everything here you go Jeremy said right
we started low we would have gone a lot
higher this is Contracting if you're
talking about the money part he said if
you want 100 everything this is the
number it's higher but these are the
non-starters this is Contracting if
you're talking about the money part he
said if you want 100 of everything this
is the number it's higher this is the
number it's higher so it was only after
the counter offer wanting more money
because 50 million dollars wasn't enough
the counter offer was for 120 million
and wanting zero pay cuts if he ended up
getting banned from spot Spotify or
iTunes or any platform that distributed
his show thus making less money for the
daily wire because they would lose ad
revenue from less people hearing the ads
then the daily wire rebuffed the
ridiculous counter offer and cut off
negotiations with Crowder realizing that
they have two very different ideas about
how to monetize content and what
Crowders is worth as soon as he said
that I know we'll never get to a deal I
can't bro why is he dressed like Edgar
friendly like what he's like Demolition
Man outfit he's wearing what's the weird
key around his neck
Ben Shapiro's heart oh isn't that
adorable that's really cute nah I'm just
kidding it's where he keeps a good
juggled
it's literally just the most basic thing
it's just for a safe that has a lot of
gold in it Shapiro has one key he has
the other they have to turn it at the
same time oh yes that's pretty dope yep
yeah mutual assured Financial
destruction is what they call out of the
daily wire
I can't guarantee 30 million dollars a
year it's an ocular scanner they're like
okay I need you to do me a favor I need
to go kill Jeremy and remove his
eyeballs and bring the mini intact all
right I killed quartering the other
Jeremy okay good job but that was the
wrong turn still great job though
remember we're not talking this is this
is boring Jeremy boring yeah and Jeremy
from the quartering right I didn't know
how I was gonna pay for 50. I thought
not that he isn't worth it but that's a
big risk 120 million dollars is an
incalculable risk for a company uh our
size Sage retail stage rates are for
five bucks just did a Mark Dice selling
mugs in the AI thing this AI thing is my
new favorite bit here you go Mark hey
iHeart is so [__] weird look at this
dice
on the bottom it says today the dice
air is the best so stupid and you know
the best part of AI art is that it makes
regular artists so angry
just the salt that it mines it's so
angry that's not real
[__] off
um you know what you artists all you
Twitter artists are you a little Fiverr
artists you people get your commissions
open in your bios you've never made me
laugh once AI artists made me laugh more
than any of you have in years
holy [__] this one's good this one's
great too
and I love how can you add Mark Dice can
you can you put the term with a mustache
Mark died can you can you do this can
you put the term with a mustache to see
if it if it adds it I love how it's like
you know procedurally kind of generated
so like there's always way too many mugs
and they're like stacked and like you
know clipped onto each other it's just
these dumb mugs everywhere it's so
stupid
AI art is is hilarious they're saying
that's clearly
that's so dumb
the first time Anthony in a picture
behind him look how weird his hand looks
they can't they can't do anything they
can't do hands just like real artists
and then look at the yeah you see the
Opie and Anthony
uh oh yeah
the back back before they hated it
better times